[Music]
Kim and Khloe Kardashian are living in a
Barbie world
[Music]
the sisters took their daughters Chicago
in true and niece's stormy and dream to
the world of Barbie exhibition in LA on
Monday it's a beautiful thing the
reality stars shared a series of snaps
from the family outing on Instagram
showing off their head to toe pink bits
we all want to be cute over here okay
that's the good American founder
flashing a peace sign posing it up with
her five-year-old daughter and her
brother Rob's little girl in a life-size
Barbie box complete with all of Barbie's
accessories isn't that crazy the girls
worked it for the cameras in front of
Barbie and Ken surfboards took a mirror
selfie hopped into Barbie's camper van
played in a ball pit checked out
Barbie's space shuttle hung out in
Barbie's kitchen and lounged on beach
chairs I don't know what's gonna top
that and Kim she shared this pic of shy
writing thank you for the most fun
experience for our girls it's really fun
to see and bands might just get a closer
look at that girls outing on the
Family's Hulu series I love that the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes if
you look closely you can see the
reflection of a camera crew in the class
case as Kim films the first Barbie
as for Kim she clearly loves being a
mama and having adventures with the four
kiddos she shares with her ex Kanye West
I want to make sure each kid gets so
much of my attention I think four is the
perfect magic number for me Azores
recently told E.T that the skims founder
is living her best life and isn't taking
herself too seriously you just gotta
roll with it she has amazing energy
right now and everyone around her loves
it safe to assume Kim's in her Barbie
era living life to the fullest
imaginations
[Music]